this video is sponsored by Squarespace
have you ever wanted to start a website
it's a more useful and popular resource
than you might think at first I mean if
you have practically any online presence
across any platform that's more than
just an account you use for browsing the
web chances are you could benefit from
having a website of your very own and
even if you're just curious Squarespace
makes testing these Waters easier than
anyone else you can visit Squarespace to
design and create your own website from
scratch or by working off of any of
their fantastic templates which is what
I did actually and my website is
beautiful for gaming creators you can
even use your own website to host your
videos and remonetize content for your
most dedicated fans by opening up
member-only areas if you'd like to of
course and what's even better is that
you can go to squarespace.com to trial
your website completely for free and
once you've spent enough time tweaking
it and you're happy with it head over to
squarespace.com Bandit to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain it really is that easy and now on
to the video
well howdy Legend of Zelda lore Partners
fancy seeing you here in a Legend of
Zelda lore video my name is Bandit and
whether you've watched the lore
breakdowns on the channel before and
need a refresher you're new to the
channel or you just need a One-Stop shop
to refer to in the future or share with
friends I've compiled each of the three
previous videos I created explaining the
lore behind every link Zelda and
appearance of Ganon in the series into
one easy to access video so without
further Ado sit back you're welcome and
uh oh yeah spoiler alert obviously
a Zelda game without link is uh not a
Zelda game actually which is kind of
weird since he's not even the character
that the series is named after top 10
anime betrayals number one but seriously
though Zelda is not Zelda without link
and if I were to ask you how many links
there are in the franchise I'm curious
what would your guess be
answer is there's actually only one Link
in the entire franchise he just goes
through time and is known as the hero of
time and solves the world's problems in
every iteration nah I'm just kidding
there's like 12 of them well 12 playable
ones anyway and they all have their own
Origins and stories and I know what
you're thinking yeah Bandit there may be
12 links but I mean come on how
difficult can Link's lore be they're all
just simple kids that become Heroes
right well yes but also no they each do
have their similarities but they also
all come from different places and end
up in different places and even span
multiple games sometimes so it's worth
it to know who's who and I thought I'd
make a shorter video covering exactly
that for each and every playable Link in
the series and if you're a fan of any of
the games I'm sure this will be of
interest to you oh and spoiler alert for
the entire series obviously playable
link number one the hero of the Skies
around the age of 17 when the game takes
place this kid has no parents at least
none that we know of seriously it's
weird how many of these games have just
no mention at all of Link's mother or
father this link is just just some
skyloftian kid who grew up in skyloft
and aspires to become a skyloft knight
which are combat and survival trained
Knights who ride atop Loft wings and
ensure the safety of everyone living in
skyloft and the surrounding floating
islands although I'm not sure why
necessarily skyloft needs Knights I mean
it's not like there are many monsters up
here terrorizing the place aside from
those evil cat monster things that I
loathe but anyway he had a normal life
you know for someone living up in the
clouds he even had a school bully which
is unfortunately kind of normal which is
depressing to say it's also heavily
implied via demise's dialogue at the end
of the game that the hero of the Skies
is The Reincarnation of the spirit of
the first hero who was also just some
dude that was the chosen champion of the
Goddess highly in the early days when
highly a waged battle against demise an
act which would forever tie the
bloodline of the goddess to the spirit
of her chosen hero Skylink is perhaps
the most important Link in the franchise
aside from the hero of time due to the
fact that he is responsible for forging
the goddess blade into the master sword
and defeating demise the origin original
big bad wolf and he and Zelda may have
repopulated the surface of the Earth but
anyway moving on playable link number
two the hero of the Minish which is
actually just a fan made title that he
doesn't actually receive in game but
this guy again is just some kid around
the age of 12 who's a blacksmith in this
game or at least the grandson of a
blacksmith known as Smith the blacksmith
he's childhood friends with the Princess
Zelda and just ends up in the wrong
place at the wrong time really when he
accompanies her to the pcori festival
which is interrupted by vati finding and
destroying the pcori blade as well as
turning Princess Zelda into stone her
father the king then tasks the hero of
the Minish with reforging the pcori
blade and breaking the curse on Zelda
and the rest is history Minish history
playable link number three the hero of
Thor which is a fan made name from me I
know naming link is one of my many gifts
but anyway this link is one of the links
with the least amount of backstory and
that he's literally just there for some
reason he just accompanies Zelda one day
to check out the pcori blade which now
goes by the name the four sword due to
the events in the Minish Cap since this
is many years after the Minish Cap but
does deal with the same villain in the
same blade it can be assumed that this
link also has a similar backstory to the
one in the Minish Cap perhaps he's also
the grandson of a blacksmith and the
childhood friend of a Zelda playable
link number four the one the only the
hero of time be honest you've heard that
catchy title before regardless of if
you've played the game and for good
reason too because aside from the first
hero of the sky the hero of time is
perhaps the most important Link in the
entire franchise because of his
Adventure directly leading to the
infamous timeline split as well as
ganondorf's many different returns
because of his importance to the story
as a whole his adventures are referenced
even in breath of the wild and any
references to the ancient hero or
legendary hero in the games following
Ocarina of Time are likely references to
the hero of time we also know a bit
about his backstory from in-game quotes
as well according to the Deku Tree
Sprout link is a Hylian who was given to
the great Deku Tree to be raised in the
Kokiri Forest as a Kokiri for safe
keeping by his mother who narrowly
escaped the hyrulean civil war with just
enough time to save her baby boy before
succumbing to her fatal wounds since
Link's father is never mentioned in
Ocarina of Time but in other games is
referred to as a knight of Hyrule it can
be assumed that the hero of times father
likely fought and died in said Civil War
as a knight of Hyrule the hero of time
is also the same link that continues
onward into the events of Majora's Mask
after he's done ridding the world of
Ganondorf before he has a chance to mess
things up he apparently then leads a
quiet life in servitude to the Hylian
royal family following the events of
Majora's Mask and shows up later on in
the timeline as a fully grown adult
ghost who is a side character to the
next playable link enter the hero of
Twilight link number five this link is
the only Link in the entire series who
is directly confirmed to be a blood
descendant of the hero of time as proven
by the fact that he inexplicably already
has the Triforce of courage in his blood
and the hero of time or wrath of the
hero Shades dialogue to link the hero of
Twilight is also a teenager around the
age of 16 to 17 that has no in-game
mention of his parents just like the
hero of the sky and many other links he
grew up in the little village of on as a
farm hand and for whatever reason is
fascinated with swordplay and is
actually very proficient at it despite
having very little actual experience in
that particular field you know prior to
the events of the game speculation tells
me that this could mean that his father
may have also been a sword fighter like
he's implied to be in other games and
that he died when link was very young
leaving the little hero with an inner
desire to be like his father no idea
about his mom though another piece of
speculation is that the hero of
Twilight's farmhand nature and knowledge
of oppona's song is proof of the hero of
times marriage to melon who is a farm
girl who created epona's song but that's
neither here nor there playable link
number six the hero of light from four
Swords Adventures in this final game
that deals with vati the evil wind Mage
and the four sword and just like the
extremely similarly named game four
Swords the hero of light does not really
have a backstory but rather just kind of
pops up when needed at the start of the
game again inexplicably connected to
Princess Zelda and the six maidens I
choose to believe that these three four
sword wielding links all have the same
backstores because parallel or is good
lore in my opinion and once again that
would mean that link was Zelda's
childhood friend and is the grandson of
a Smithy named Smith but that's just my
guess changing timelines playable ink
number seven would be the hero of winds
who is the first link in the adult
timeline now this is where Link's
backstory starts to get pretty
interesting but let's start with what we
know for a fact about this link
according to AO Numa directly he's meant
to be around 12 years old which is
backed up by the Super Smash Brothers
Brawl Toon Link trophy link lives in the
adult timeline following a great flood
on an island known as outside island
with his grandmother and little sister
named Errol again though we're not sure
what happened to Link's parents but
since arrow is pretty young like maybe
around eight or nine years of age and
the two of them live with their
grandmother we can assume that something
bad probably happened to Link's parents
not too terribly long ago and that they
are permanently out of the picture
because of this hence why the kids were
then given to their grandmother for safe
keeping instead but now for the fun part
his theoretical non-connection to the
spirit of the hero this is a pretty well
known Theory but keep in mind that it's
still just a theory and you're are free
to believe it or not depending on what
you feel like but anyway it's theorized
that unlike the vast majority of the
other links in the Zelda series the hero
of winds is actually not connected to
the spirit of the hero this is because
Princess Zelda in Ocarina of Time sent
the hero of time back in time spawning
the child and adult timelines and
removing the hero from the adult
timeline altogether this is also why the
Triforce of Courage and the Wind Waker
is scattered at the bottom of the ocean
because it shattered when the hero was
removed from the timeline unlike living
on within the hero's bloodline as proven
by the hero of Twilight in the child
timeline was that confusing okay let me
summarize real quick what this means
essentially is that the hero of winds
really was just some kid completely
disconnected from any heroic Spirits or
Bloodlines that came before he just
really wanted to save his little sister
and figured Ah hell why not save the
rest of the world while I'm at it also
after his adventure with Tetra Zelda
ends at the end of the game in Ganondorf
and the last king of Hyrule are sealed
away once and for all beneath the waves
the two actually go on another adventure
which spawns the events of the Phantom
Hourglass and take takes place in
another ocean realm known as the world
of the ocean King it's actually pretty
similar to the Hyrule versus Terminus
setup but anyway that's the hero of
winds in a nutshell moving on the next
playable link so link number eight is
the hero of trains from The Game's
Spirit Tracks that takes place
apparently 100 years or so after the
events of the hero of wins in a new land
called new Hyrule which was founded by
the hero of winds and Tetra Zelda it's
unknown if this link is the descendant
of the hero of winds actually it's kind
of improbable for a reason I'll get into
in just a bit but either way he also
does not have any parents with him when
we meet him in game go figure he's just
a kid from a village known as Adoba
Village and lives with Nico the very
same Nico that once was a pirate serving
under the pirate Captain Tetra only he's
an old man now link is also The
Apprentice of a master train engineer
named Alfonso who trained link no pun
intended into becoming a royal engineer
himself and the rest is history the
reason why I don't think the hero of
trains is physically related to the hero
of winds is because you'd think that
Nico would know if this link was the
descendant of the older link he even
tells link that he looks like the hero
of wind who he refers to as an old
friend of his anyway I guess the hero of
trains is to the hero of winds what the
hero of winds was to the hero of time a
disconnected but similarly Brave hero
that also goes to prove the absence of a
spirit of the hero in the adult timeline
well that and the complete absence of
any mention of the Triforce at all in
the game aside from some symbols with
the adult and child timelines out of the
way it's time to move on to the
problematic one the what if styled
alternate reality of the Fallen timeline
in this timeline or should I say in this
reality Ganondorf transformed into Ganon
and killed the hero of time in Ocarina
of Time leaving the job of sealing him
away up to the sages alone which worked
except for the fact that they kind of
sort of sealed him away within the
sacred realm and he corrupted the whole
thing turning it into the dark world but
what is this in all iterations of Canon
explained
no it's not so the next playable Link
Link number nine is the hero of Hyrule
from A Link to the Past who is in
another of the more impactful links in
the series due to having the most games
under his belt that feature him in this
game link lives with his uncle again
with no parents to be seen but at least
we're getting closer the game starts
with Princess Zelda being captured by
Agony which is ganon's Alter Ego
telepathically communicating with link
and his uncle pleading them to come and
Aid her they both hear this calling
because they're both of the blood of the
Knights of Hyrule which is a clan of
Warriors said to be descendants of the
legendary hero which either refers to
the hero of time or the hero of the sky
either way Link's uncle is killed trying
to rescue Zelda so link takes up the
mantle and the rest is history by the
way if you're interested in learning
more about Link's connections to the
Knights of Hyrule and even their
possible connections to the dark nut
enemies check out the theory of mind
about just that anyway after the hero of
Hyrule defeats Ganon who fights him with
the power of the Triforce he goes on to
have a few more Adventures the first of
which is Link's Awakening which used to
take place after the Oracle games but
now takes place before them because
Nintendo just decided to swap around the
timeline like that probably to prove he
doesn't die at sea after the game ends
but anyway that adventure takes place
while link is sailing away from Hyrule
in Surge of Adventure elsewhere within a
dream of a wind fish but eventually he
does go on some real adventures in the
lands of holodrum and librina in the
Oracle of Seasons and Oracle of Ages
games respectively he also meets two
girls known as DIN and nehru in those
lands which is definitely some potential
Theory material the next playable link
and the third to last is the new hero of
Hyrule link number 10. this link is once
again not proven to be connected to the
previous link the first year of Hyrule
though I guess either one could be
assumed since the spirit of the hero was
never split off from this reality but
rather was just killed as a hero of time
previously it can be assumed that every
hero in the child and Fallen timelines
are all incarnations of said spirit so
whether or not they're related by blood
isn't really important the new hero of
Hyrule solves both Laurel and hyrule's
problems regarding their triforces and
then goes on to have another fashion
emergency Adventure in Triforce Heroes
which despite the name has actually
nothing to do with the Triforce there
are also two other links that accompany
the new hero of Hyrule in this adventure
but literally according to Nintendo it
cannot be known who they are or where
they come from perhaps their links from
other realities I mean the entire Fallen
timeline is a different reality that
happens if the hero of time is killed so
what if we you know what I'm gonna stop
there actually the second to last
playable link and the last one with a
confirmed location on the timeline is
the original hero from the original
Legend of Zelda and I mean original hero
as in the first one we saw in real life
on the timeline however he's actually
quite futuristic this link is literally
a 10 or 12 year old swords boy who impa
Zelda's assistant is saved by when she
was attacked by ganon's henchmen it just
so happens that she had been tasked with
finding a capable man of Bravery to lead
the fight against ganon's forces and
save the kingdom and with link showing
such skill at such a young age and
nobody else really being around she
thought ah what the hell and asked him
to save the land the Triforce and the
princess altogether all of which he does
of course once again though we're back
to having no mention of his parents at
all which should surprise no one at this
point this link also goes on to another
adventure when he's around 16 years of
age in the game known as The Adventure
of link where he finds and awakens an
ancient Princess Zelda who had been put
into a magical Slumber by her brother
long ago fun fact when she awakens at
the end this means that there are
literally two princess zeldas alive in
the world at the end of the Fallen
timeline at the same time fun stuff the
final playable link and the one most
fresh on everyone's memory and the one
with the biggest and most blue eyes of
them all would be the one the only the
hero of the Wilds known for his
adventures and sick climbing skills in
breath of the wild wild Link's father is
actually directly referenced for the
first time ever in a Zelda game by
Princess Zelda herself and we even have
concept art for him that unfortunately
never made it into the game Zelda claims
that Link's dad was a knight of Hyrule
which makes sense given other Link's
affiliations with the group it even
explains why link himself is in service
of Zelda and the royal family directly
as he simply wanted to follow in his
Father's Footsteps his age is never
outright confirmed of what we can assume
that he is the same age as Zelda which
is normally the case in the other games
which would mean that he has just turned
17 by the time the game starts or should
I say 117 as most fans undoubtedly know
the hero of the Wilds takes on the
essence of demise's hateful malice
itself known as the Calamity Ganon and
together with the princess seals it away
once again but who knows maybe that
entire fight was just small potatoes
compared to what's to come in tears of
the Kingdom I guess we'll just have to
find out next may but for now that is
the end of my list explaining briefly
the lore behind every playable Link in
the entire series with a few mentions to
the links not playable in the series did
you know everything mentioned
hey guys it's me Bandit I know it's been
a little while since my last upload but
things have happened I randomly woke up
in New York City for instance but of
course you would have known that if you
followed me on Instagram but anyway I'm
back and wanted to start the year off
fresh with covering Zelda as in the
princess from the series The Legend of
Zelda you may think you know all there
is to know about the well-known princess
who gives Toadstool a run for her money
in the how many times can you be
kidnapped competition but think again
for instance did you know that unlike
the spirit of the hero Zelda is more of
a descendant than a reincarnation and
every daughter born into the original
Zelda's bloodline after a certain point
in the timeline was to be named Zelda
meaning technically there have been an
infinite unknowable number of zeldas
that we've never even met or how about
the fact that at one point there were
two completely different princess zeldas
alive and in existence at the same time
in the same timeline oh yeah zeldelor
goes hard and that my friends is the
name of the game for this video so
without further Ado let us delve into
explaining each iteration of Zelda that
we know of in the games oh and spoiler
alert for the in entire franchise
obviously since it's easier to explain
in Universe lore when following the
in-universe lore timeline we're going to
cover the Zelda appearances in the order
they take place on the timeline starting
with the very first Zelda from Skyward
Sword this Zelda is different from every
other Zelda in that she's not actually
royalty well not yet at least since the
royal family exists immediately
following this game and is composed of
her descendants it can be assumed that
Skyward Zelda started the Royal Family
when she and Link probably you know
populated the surface of the Earth but
anyway it was due to the Events and
Adventures surrounding Skyward Zelda's
life that we were able to discover her
true identity and that is that she is
The Reincarnation of the goddess hylia
who is probably the goddess of time but
that's a whole other Theory and
therefore her bloodline is not only
Royal but is literally Supernatural and
yes her Supernatural blood gives her and
her descendants super powers she's the
full package but besides her return to
the surface and the founding of Hyrule
there's not much else to say about Good
Old Skyward Zelda so moving on the next
Zelda that pops up on the timeline is
the princess from the Minish Cap we'll
call her Minish Zelda now Minish Zelda
serves to kind of throw a wrench in the
whole Zelda's having powers due to
highly a bloodline thing because Minish
Zelda has a presumably different Power
flowing through her veins according to
vati the main enemy of the game see long
ago the teeny tiny little Minish people
descended down to the land of
regular-sized people and gave the
ancient hylians a magical power called
the light Force this light Force which
originated not from hylia but from Tiny
Sky people was similarly placed within
the bloodline of hyrule's princess and
is said to be a source of Limitless
magical power so just to be clear at
this point in the timeline princess
zeldas have both goddess powers and the
unlimited source of magical power called
the light force in their bloodlines I
suppose a theory could be made that
they're one and the same but well maybe
I'll talk more about that in another
video hint hint wink wink subscribe back
to Minish Zelda though besides the whole
light force in her blood thing the only
other chewy piece of lore that she she
gives to the series would be the fact
that she is the first Princess Zelda and
that's about it the next Princess Zelda
is the Zelda from four Swords similarly
to the previous two she also was a
childhood friend of her link and helps
link defeat vati once again who tried to
marry her
yup the next Princess Zelda is one of
the most important if not the de facto
most important Zelda to the lore of the
franchise and I'm not just saying that
because Ocarina of Time is my favorite
game of all time okay maybe I am a
little bit but seriously she has a very
fleshed out story and is also literally
the reason why the timeline splits in
the first place well she's the reason
why it splits between adult and child
that is the Fallen timeline exists
either way but we don't explain that
when using actual logic anyway Ocarina
Zelda who is also the same Zelda that
kind of makes an appearance in Majora's
Mask is the first Zelda who alongside
the hero of time we get to see both as a
child and as an adult and in both
instances she kind of sort of messes
everything up despite trying her hardest
to do the right thing hashtag relatable
I go into this in much more detail in an
old video of mine I did explaining
Ocarina Zelda's big mistake but in a
nutshell as a child she was given
prophetic dreams which detailed Evil
coming to the world and a boy in green
being the key to saving everyone in an
attempt to do something with her Visions
she tried to bring it up to her father
who apparently didn't listen to her some
something that Kings of Hyrule have in
common with one another apparently since
her father lent her no ear she took
matters into her own hands when link the
weird green forest boy from her dreams
randomly came to see her she tells link
to get the master sword which he does
which ends up putting link to sleep for
seven years and leaving the door to the
sacred realm and therefore the Triforce
wide freaking open allowing Ganondorf to
just Waltz right in and touch it with
his greasy Gerudo fingers Zelda and impa
go into hiding for seven years and in
that time Zelda trains hard to become an
epic gender swap sheikah ninja named
Chic in order to thwart ganondorf's best
efforts to find her anyway once link has
awoken from his Slumber seven years
later and is Guided by Zelda I mean Chic
towards the ultimate goal of Awakening
all the sages Sheik reveals himself as
the Princess Zelda herself and
immediately gets captured by Ganondorf
after which link rescues her and
normally this is where a happily ever
after would come into play but not for
Ocarina Zelda see she was so racked with
guilt over the whole link losing his
childhood in the world being plunged
into seven long years of horribleness
thing since really it was kind of her
fault that it all happened so to rectify
what she could for link she decides to
send him back to his original timeline
removing the hero of time from the adult
timeline and permanently splitting the
timeline into adult and child and this
is where a multitude of theories take
place such as the rather controversial
theory that the spirit of the hero
itself was removed from the adult
timeline because of this leading to no
hero Rising when the world needed him
again when Ganon broke out of a seal
prior to the events of the Wind Waker or
my theory that the master sword was
removed from the adult timeline because
of this leading to another blade taking
its place also in the Wind Waker anyway
we've spent a lot of time discussing
Ocarina Zelda but the last thing I'll
mention is that she has two existences
by the end of the game the grown-up
Ocarina Zelda we see at the end that
lives on in the adult timeline and
probably helps restore Hyrule and the
kid Ocarina Zelda we see at the end that
lives on in the child timeline and gives
link the Ocarina of Time once again
before he goes on his next adventure in
termina moving on we'll cover the adult
timeline Zelda's first since I mentioned
wind waker's so much Princess Zelda and
the Wind Waker actually has no idea
she's a princess until you're a good
ways into the game and before that she's
a young 12 year old pirate Queen who
went by the name Tetra and inherited a
ship and its crew once her mother the
previous pirate Queen passed away Tetra
as far as we can tell was born at sea
but is obviously a descendant of Ocarina
Zelda and because of this we can
actually see a giant picture of an
ancestor of her lineage down in the
submerged Hyrule Castle a previous Zelda
who also had a crew I guess positioned
around her which mimics the current
pirate crew exactly implying that Tetra
and her crew are all descendants of
these ancestors along with her bloodline
she also carried with her a fragment of
the Triforce of wisdom which had been
passed down from mother to daughter
following the fall of Hyrule and the
flooding of the world as per the events
of the game eventually Tetra now wearing
a dress and going by the name Zelda
helps link defeat Ganondorf and the
world of Hyrule is drowned once and for
all and then Zelda takes off her dress
and goes back to going by the name Tetra
and sails off with link for more
Adventures at Sea she does make a slight
appearance in the game's direct sequel
the Phantom Hourglass where she is
pretty much immediately captured until
the end of the game at which point she
returns to the pirate's life however the
next Zelda in the adult timeline is a
descendant of tetra Zelda who discovered
a new land with link and founded New
Hyrule and the new royal family before
passing away Spirit track Zelda is
specifically tetra's
great-great-granddaughter and shares a
backstory with the four sword Zelda in
that she's been a childhood friend of
link and pulls an Ocarina Zelda by
secretly meeting with Lincoln plotting
to investigate matters without involving
any adults in this case they begin
investigating The Disappearance of the
spirit tracks also she is actually the
first playable Zelda in the franchise
which is a huge milestone for the series
hmm what's that you say you remember
another playable Zelda before Spirit
Tracks Zelda
no you don't that was just a bad dream
anyway Spirit track Zelda also serves as
the game's companion character after
she's uh killed actually well not killed
per se but her soul leaves her body so
you tell me what that means any anyway
bada bing bada boom she and Link kick
all sorts of booty and eventually link
exercises princess Zelda's possessed
body and she's able to regain it after
which they kick the new Demon King
melodus booty and restore order to the
land of new Hyrule together and now the
adult timeline has a happily ever after
ending moving over to the child timeline
the first Zelda to appear in a game
after Ocarina Zelda does in Majora's
Mask would be Twilight Zelda from the
game Twilight Princess now in the child
timeline ganondorf's takeover of Hyrule
was prevented due to link going back in
time and well preventing it however the
Triforce was still split into three
pieces somehow which means that it may
exist outside of the timelines but that
is not a subject I'm willing to get into
right now I said that because in
Twilight Princess the descendants of the
hero of time and Ocarina Zelda both
already have their pieces of the
Triforce in their bloodlines which is
really neither here nor there but I just
wanted to cover it real quick anyway
Twilight Zelda by the time the game
takes place is the sole ruler of Hyrule
which is proven by the fact that when
Zant barges into the throne room to take
it over it's Zelda herself that he
approaches and not a king anybody else
which should mean that technically she
should be Queen Zelda so I'm just gonna
call her Queen Zelda from now on anyway
zand forces Queen Zelda to surrender and
thus plunges the world of Hyrule into
Twilight with Zelda being held prisoner
in her own castle which I guess could be
worse All Things Considered I mean at
least she has a view of the Kingdom that
she surrendered whose inhabitants are
now eternally suffering anyway
eventually Link in the real Twilight
Princess named midna approach Zelda
while midna is dying after Zan
forcefully plunges her into the light as
a being of Twilight her life begins to
fade very quickly but just before she
takes her last breath Queens outer
decides to sacrifice her Essence in
order to save midna's life transforming
midna from being just a being of
Twilight into a being of both light and
Twilight now I'd like to interject a
little mini theory of mine regarding how
Zelda was able to do this and dissipate
entirely but yet also have her soulless
body show up later in order to be
possessed by Ganondorf I mean if this
was Zelda's body that just disappeared
Into Thin Air what did Ganondorf just
conjure up a new body in Zelda's image
just because as he wanted to possess a
Zelda I think not personally I think the
answer is tied to why she's strangely
able to resist turning into a spirit
like all the other hyruleans do when
exposed to Twilight simply put I think
she actually is a spirit here similar to
the other spirits but not quite see I
think that perhaps she was granted some
special protections from her piece of
the Triforce when subjected to the
influence of Twilight just like link
when he was turned into a wolf instead
of a spirit and if you think about it we
already know that the Triforce pieces
protect their bearers from twice protect
their bearers from Twilight but act
differently when exposed to Twilight the
Triforce of Courage turns its Bearer
into a courageous Beast while the
Triforce of power turns its Bearer into
literally a flaming ball of power so
what if the Triforce of wisdom allows
its Bearer to manifest their Spirit or
their mind's Essence from within their
body in order to still be interact with
other beings of light or Twilight what
I'm saying is what if Queen Zelda's body
never left the throne room and we're
actually speaking to her Triforce
enabled spirit in the castle tower or or
maybe it's a holographic double of her
body which is something that the sheikah
have been known to do which is why she's
wearing a chica cloak but you know
regardless after defeating her Ganondorf
possessed body Zelda's Essence leaves
midna and returns to her own body after
which she AIDS Lincoln 25 of the battle
against Ganondorf by shooting him with
light arrows on Horseback once he's
finally dead and gone after the
climactic four-part battle Zelda is seen
saying goodbye to midnight the mirror of
twilight forever and afterwards
presumably returns to her rightful place
at the Throne of Hyrule later on in the
timeline four Swords Adventures takes
place which features the next Zelda once
again it can be assumed that she was
childhood friends with link like the
Zelda from four Swords but like the
Zelda from a link to the past which we
haven't gotten to just yet she is able
to telepathically communicate with link
and asks him to join her at the four
sword sanctuary in order to check up on
what's going on with all the ominous
Clouds Of Darkness covering the land
turns out it was a trap by shadowlink
and vati once again is released upon
link drawing the four sword vati once
again kidnaps a Zelda for the third time
now and Zelda after being rescued by
link AIDS Link in the feeding Ganon the
end moving over to the Fallen timeline
or as we should call it the alternate
reality in which link dies at the end of
Ocarina of Time the first Zelda that
appears after Ocarina Zelda would be the
prince of Zelda of a link to the past
this Zelda starts off the game by
telepathically communicating with the
members of the Knights of Hyrule which
in this case means link and his uncle
she asks for help because she's been
kidnapped by the wizard Agony who was
trying to sacrifice all of the
descendants of the seven wise men to
undo their seal on Ganon in the Dark
World which he was imprisoned within
after he offed link anyway link is not
able to sell Zelda and she gets
sacrificed straight up which in this
universe means that she gets sent to the
Dark World trapped on top of Death
Mountain she doesn't do too much after
this point because well she can't and
eventually link frees her and wishes
upon the Triforce for evil to be
dispelled from the land after which
Zelda is able to return to Hyrule this
Zelda is the same Zelda that is
referenced in the Oracle games and even
kidnapped once again go figure if the
games are linked twin rova who
apparently was not killed in the Fallen
timeline is the one who kidnaps Zelda at
this point and attempts to sacrifice her
in order to resurrect their son
Ganondorf link prevents this but they
end up just sacrificing themselves in
order to resurrect a Mindless version of
Ganondorf Ganon who is beaten by link
and once again Zelda is able to return
to Hyrule unscathed but probably
traumatized the next Zelda that pops up
is the Zelda from A Link Between Worlds
who like Twilight Zona rules over her
land alone without a father or a mother
or a Suitor when she first meets link
she is warned about Yuga running around
turning people into paintings and being
generally obnoxious at which point she
tells link to go Warn sahasrilla and
gives him the pendant of Courage which
is one of the three pendants of virtue
necessary for drawing the master sword
from deep within the Lost Woods in this
game and in A Link to the Past she did
this because she had a feeling that they
just might need a hero and boy was she
right because not too long afterwards
Yuga comes for Zelda herself and ends up
kidnapping her by turning her into a
beautiful painting and Yanks her into
Laurel with link following behind and
similarly to Agony from A Link to the
Past just Yuga uses Zelda and the rest
of the sages to revive Ganon and then
merge with Ganon forming Yuga again and
who eventually will be defeated by link
Zelda and Hyrule are saved at this point
but before I move on to the next Zelda
in the timeline I'm going to cover the
other Zelda In This Very game and by
that I mean low rules version of Zelda
the princess Hilda who has a lot to do
with the story because she's actually
the one behind yuga's actions honestly
I'm still very impressed with this game
for pulling one over on us like that
Yugo was actually Hilda's Court Mage but
I'll get to that in a second see she's
nice for the majority of the game and
quote unquote stops yug again and from
killing link after link arrives in low
Rule and even serves to telepathically
guide link as he Journeys across both
lands and it isn't until the end of the
game that we finally get upside down
Zelda's backstory Hilda's version of
Hyrule called Low rule used to have its
own Triforce which similarly to hyrule's
Triforce was also brutally fought over
by the low rulian inhabitants differing
from Hyrule however Hilda's ancestors
decided to to use the Triforce to
destroy the Triforce which is the kind
of big brain move that would make Thanos
proud but mistake Laurel can't actually
survive without a Triforce it was never
designed to so Hilda instead searched
for another Triforce and she found one
our Triforce hyrules Triforce so at the
end of the game she reveals that our
Triforce is what she and Yuga were after
all along and she then steals Zelda's
Triforce of wisdom and summons yug again
and once again who has ganon's Triforce
of power somehow in commands Yuga Ganon
to straight up kill Link in order to
gain the Triforce of Courage which is
unsuccessful because she forgot Link's
kind of a badass Hilda then asks Yuga
Ganon to give her his piece but yug
again and says okay I hear you but what
if you gave me yours and then he takes
her piece in an act of brutal betrayal
and then turns Hilda into a painting
herself and absorbs her after link
defeats him yet again both Triforce
pieces and Hilda are released from Yuga
ganon's gut hilde then actually starts
to try to attack link but is stopped by
upside down link also known as ravio the
Cowardly rabbit dude after talking with
ravio she finally sees the error in her
ways and sends Link and Zelda back to
Hyrule who in return wish upon hyrule's
Triforce to restore low-roll's Triforce
which is the Zelda Universe equivalent
of wishing for more wishes but the point
is it works and both this Zelda and this
Hilda live happily ever after as far as
we can tell the third to last Zelda in
the series pops up in the next game in
the Fallen timeline the original Legend
of Zelda she's got a bit of a simple
story in that she breaks her Triforce of
wisdom into eight pieces and scatters
them across the land in order to hide
them from Ganon who has been resurrected
by his followers prior to the events of
the game yeah that keeps happening
someone should do something about that
she sends her handmaiden impa out to
look for a hero impa finds a 10 year old
with a sword and goes hey you know what
that could work and thus enlists the
child known as Link in the service of
saving the world Ganon reaches Zelda in
the meantime and imprisons her
underneath Death Mountain where she
waits until the end of the game when
link saves her and in her gratitude she
says thanks link you're the hero of
Hyrule
moving on the next game and last game in
the child timeline is the adventure of
Link which takes place six years after
the previous game and technically
features the same Princess Zelda
although she never actually makes an
appearance due to you know ruling Hyrule
and all that however the entire point of
Link's journey in this game is to find
and awaken an ancient Sleeping Princess
Zelda who is the next Zelda that I'll be
talking about now Sleeping Beauty Zelda
was the princess of Hyrule long ago when
it was ruled by her father and following
her father's death her brother the
prince it is said that her father used
the Triforce for good and made Hyrule
all nice and peachy but after he died he
decided for whatever reason to not tell
his son where to find the entire
Triforce but told his daughter Zelda
instead I guess she was the favorite
Child at this point some random wizard
perhaps even another residual Alter Ego
of Ganon appears and tells the prince
that his sister knows where the other
pieces are at which point both The
Prince and the wizard angrily question
Zelda but the stubborn Sleeping Beauty
gives them nothing likely out of fear
that the triforce's ultimate wishing
power would be misused which is a
healthy fear however the wizard got
upset and places Zelda into an eternal
Slumber and then dies after casting the
spell this was not at all what the
prince wanted to happen because after
all he loved his sister and therefore
this made him pretty upset and it's
because of this very story that he being
the new king of Hyrule decreed that all
daughters Born Into The Royal lineage
would therefore be named Zelda anyway
that being said eventually link saves
her and wakes her up from her ancient
sleep and she says you saved Hyrule and
you are a real hero then they kiss and
you cannot convince me otherwise the
most notable thing about the existence
of Sleeping Beauty Zelda to me is the
fact that at this point in time there
are legitimately two princess zeldas
alive at the same time this one and the
one from the previous game who's
currently ruling Hyrule the question is
following the adventure of Link doesn't
this mean that there are now two Royal
Family Lines I mean come on did nobody
at Nintendo really think this one
through did they forget somehow I doubt
we will ever get an answer to that the
final Prince of Zelda in the series
would be the one and only Zelda of the
wild from breath of the wild now this
Zelda is probably the most popular of
all the zeldas on account of her being
from the most popular Zelda game of all
time and because of that I'll just
briefly touch on her story since most of
you probably know all there is to know
about her by now in a shell of a nut she
was as every Zelda before her besides
Skyward Zelda born a princess of Hyrule
but unlike her mother and presumably all
the other females of the Royal Line she
was never able to unlock the powers of
her bloodline this caused her to try to
find other ways to Aid the land of
Hyrule and thus she partnered closely
with her sheika friends and became
somewhat of a scientist herself she even
went so far as to lead the five chosen
hyrulean Champions who were each chosen
to Pilot a Divine Beast following the
prophecy of ganon's return and the
discovery of the ancient chica
automations however she never stopped
trying to unlock her powers people like
her father and the influence of the all
too successful link who was the same age
as her didn't let her forget if anything
it just added to her overall stress poor
thing it wasn't until Calamity Ganon
finally reared its ugly head on her 17th
birthday of all days and after everyone
she knew had died except for link that
her powers finally unlocked in order to
save Link's life at the very last second
it's called love people anyway after
that she sends link off to the shrine of
Resurrection where it spends 100
freaking years rebuilding his body and
goes off to Hyrule Castle herself to
contain Calamity Ganon until link
revives and is able to you know be a
hero telepathically communicating with
him all the while link does indeed kick
Calamity booty and Zelda is able to seal
it away using the last of her power she
did have a 100 Year run with it though
so I'm sure she's good for now following
the events of breath of the wild
apparently the Chica machine stopped
working such as varuta and presumably
Link and Zelda set off to investigate
and we have now officially fully
explained every Zelda and even alternate
universe Zelda there is in the franchise
all the way until Zelda of the Wild's
upcoming appearance in tears of the
kingdom of course but the only thing we
know about her in game so far is that
she's rocking a new haircut and also she
might be dead I'm looking forward to
finding out in just over 100 days though
if you're looking forward to finding out
a Zelda game without Ganon is actually
kind of typical which is pretty weird to
think about because even though
technically speaking Ganon is the
original Zelda villain from a real life
perspective he's not the original
villain when it comes to in-game lore
and he's only present in like half of
the games but that aside clearly Ganon
is the most recognizable zeld villain of
them all and one of the most well-known
in gaming as a whole not only due to the
fact that he did originate from the
first game in the 80s but also because
he's just playing cool and ironically is
one of the famous chosen three who
received the power of the Triforce at
several different points in the series
this depth makes him stand out as a
unique villain and in this video I'm
going to explain the lore behind every
appearance of Ganon throughout the
series oh and spoiler alert obviously
the first things that I'm going to
tackle are a couple of burning questions
that some of you no doubt have the first
of which would be what is the difference
if any between Ganon and Ganon Dwarf
what a great question I'm so glad you
asked Ganondorf although not present in
the series until the fifth game in the
frame franchise Ocarina of Time actually
comes before Ganon as far as lore is
concerned what I mean by that is that
Ganondorf the Gerudo human being was
first and then transformed into Ganon
via the power of the Triforce of power
now this is slightly theoretical and
you're more than welcome to disagree
with me because of that as is your
prerogative when discussing things not
directly confirmed in game but my
understanding is that Ganon is the
Demonic Beast form that Ganondorf
transforms into when augmented by a
great power source such as the Triforce
or the Twilight or malice and this
explanation for ganon's existence is
what I'll be branching off of for the
entirety of this video the second
burning question that you may have is
what do I mean every cannon in the
series isn't there just one well yes but
also no most ganons are actually the
same yes just split up by different
timelines and appear differently
depending on multiple different factors
however one Ganon in particular is
actually a straight-up reincarnation and
therefore another Ganon entirely you see
in the child timeline which we'll get
back to at some point later in the video
Ganondorf is killed straight up but then
another Ganondorf is born at some point
in the future and eventually transforms
into another Ganon and subsequently gets
sealed away at the end of four Swords
Adventures that being said each
appearance whether the same Ganon slash
dwarf or not will be covered in full
detail so just hang tight the last
question to tackle before getting into
the nitty-gritty would be the question
of whether or not Ganon is the literal
Reincarnation of demise's hatred which
as many people will remember is the
beginning of the seemingly endless cycle
of Good vs Evil that we see happen in
every Zelda game my answer to that is no
Ganon is not the literal incarnation of
demise's hatred at least not directly
he's more of a byproduct see a lot of
people including me formally assume that
Ganon is the demon that demises Eternal
hatred manifests as but that explanation
doesn't allow for the existence of other
demon Kings and Lords such as malidis or
Majora which also embody the hatred of
demise instead I now believe that demise
simply cursed his hatred into a
reincarnating existence in the exact
same way that link or the spirit of the
hero reincarnates and similarly to the
spirit of the hero will always
reincarnate as an individual that may
then become augmented and turn into a
demon this automatically explains every
major demon in every major antagonist
such as vati or Ganondorf or the other
Ganondorf because once one of them dies
another will eventually reincarnate due
to the curse just like another link will
eventually reincarnate due to the
blessing if you will yet another
similarity and parallelism between hylia
and demise but that's enough talking
about not Ganon and ganon's own video so
let's move on according to prophecy that
was set in place an unknown time ago by
forces currently unknowable the desert
dwelling Gerudo people give birth to a
male child only once every hundred years
and once of age that boy is by default
to become the king of the Gerudo this
was the age-old custom of the Gerudo
until one particular boy was born in
crowned King and his name was Ganondorf
he was born long ago before the events
of Ocarina of Time and is introduced to
us in-game as the Gerudo King who
apparently swore allegiance to the king
of Hyrule however as Zelda correctly
predicted this Allegiance was fake and
ganondorf's true intent was to find and
seize the Triforce for himself which was
under the protection of the royal family
of Hyrule and that's the only backstory
to Ganondorf that we had all the way
until his appearance in the Wind Waker
when we finally were able to realize the
deeper reasoning behind his actions
which put simply he did out of jealousy
as the ruler of the Gerudo he knew
firsthand of all the hardships that come
with living in the desert and he wanted
the land of Hyrule for his own because
of this however instead of acting nobly
and perhaps collaborating somehow with
the king of Hyrule to alleviate the
harsh living conditions of his people he
instead sought to usurp the Throne of
Hyrule forcefully and take its
omnipotent Triforce for his own no
matter his reasoning though he
eventually did discover the Triforce and
upon attempting to touch it split it
apart into the three pieces of power
wisdom and courage which rested within
Ganondorf Zelda and Link respectively
for seven long years he searched for the
other two pieces while sitting in top
his stolen Throne of Hyrule and
eventually link brings both himself and
Zelda to ganondorf's front door after
being defeated by Link in combat
Ganondorf calls upon the power of the
Triforce of power within him and
transforms into a hideous demon
introducing the world to the monster
known as Ganon the effects and Legacy of
which we have yet to escape to this day
it's also worth mentioning that ever
since ganondorf's Reign Over the Gerudo
and transformation into the Demon King
Ganon the Gerudo people have officially
sworn off all males assumedly including
their own it's confirmed that there have
been no Kings since Ganondorf but it's
unknown as to whether or not there have
still been other Garuda men born but
back to Ganon as a side note for what
it's worth I think that Phantom ganons
are named Phantom Ganon instead of
phantom Ganon Dwarf even though they
directly look like Ganondorf instead of
Ganon because Ganon is also the term we
use for Magical doppelgangers of
Ganondorf if you will that's really
neither here nor there but I just wanted
to take a moment and explain my thought
process since technically Phantom ganons
are you know ganons at least in name but
back to Ganon Ganon as you know
following the events of Ocarina of Time
the timeline splits into three separate
ones the adult which follows the events
pictured here the child which follows
the events pictured here and the Fallen
which follows events we don't see
actually since it's more of an alternate
reality where Ganon manages to defeat
Link in each of these timelines we see
Ganon again but notably in vastly
different appearances in the adult
timeline he appears again as a puppet
something unable to move on its own in
the child timeline he appears as a
four-legged beast and is the only time
he appears this way in the entire series
aside from breath of the wild and in the
Fallen timeline he appears similarly to
his original Ocarina of Time appearance
as a two-legged humanoid Pigman monster
thing now I happen to believe that the
differing appearances are no coincidence
at all and allow me to explain in the
first place I don't think the Ganon
transformation is reversible at least
the Ganon that Ganondorf transforms into
I think the only times we see Ganondorf
transform into Ganon and then back into
Ganondorf are specifically occasions
where link is able to kill Ganon such as
at the end of Ocarina of Time or
Twilight Princess in both of these
circumstances Ganondorf still had the
Triforce of power in his possession
which likely prevented him from
completely dying after link does
something like this now I know some of
you will immediately think about the
ending scene of Twilight Princess where
Ganondorf still having the Triforce of
power inside him still ends up dying but
I've already concocted an entire theory
about that subject exactly which I will
not explain here for a lack of time so
if you're interested check out my video
on that exact subject which will be
linked below anyway if we think about it
this way as in if Ganon is a permanent
transformation unless defeated this
would automatically explain each
differing appearance puppet Ganon from
Wind Waker strangely appears as a
lifeless puppet and after being defeated
it's revealed that it truly was not
Ganondorf after all and in fact the real
Ganondorf had been chilling on top of
the giant chandelier thing controlling
puppet Ganon the whole time so let's
imagine for a moment that since Wind
Waker takes place after the events at
the end of Ocarina of Time in the adult
timeline where link kills Ganon that
form can no longer be transformed into
because of this Ganondorf who has been
making several Phantom ganons in the
game creates a final Phantom Ganon that
transforms into puppet Ganon which
Ganondorf controls directly instead of
actually transforming into it himself by
contrast in the child timeline which
takes place before Ganondorf was ever
able to transform into Ganon in the
first place at the end the Gerudo King
calls upon the power of the Twilight to
accomplish several things such as
possessing Princess Zelda and after
being squeezed out of her transforming
into dark Beast Ganon which by the way
is the only other four-legged Ganon
aside from the Ganon in breath of the
wild who's also referred to as the dark
Beast Ganon almost as if to imply that
they are different Transformations
because they transformed due to
different power sources Twilight and
Malice and the reason he transformed
into more of a beast in Twilight
Princess is in my opinion the same
reason that link transforms into a wolf
in the same game it's due to the
exposure to Twilight since both link and
Ganondorf have triforces in their
systems and Link transforms into a wolf
exposed why not Ganondorf into a wolf
Pig thing and after his defeat is Ganon
he de-transforms into a ball of pure
energy does battle with midna then
appears in Hyrule Field as Ganondorf
once again with dark Beast Ganon dead
and gone at this point never to be seen
again later on in the timeline following
ganondorf's death at the end of Twilight
Princess another Ganondorf is born and I
know four Swords Adventures lore is kind
of messy because of this but hey it's
Canon and it's on the timeline ride here
so it's got to have some sort of
explanation which is that demises hatred
once again reincarnates as another
Ganondorf but this time he transforms
into Ganon via unknown means it can be
assumed though that he transformed
because he obtained the Trident but like
I said it's unclear since you really
don't see Ganon or Ganondorf at all in
the game and the Triforce is nowhere to
be seen anyway in the alternate reality
called the Fallen timeline Ganondorf
transforms into Ganon but is actually
able to kill link however due to link
having already awakened the sages and
according to the intro of A Link to the
Past Ganon was stopped by the Sage's aka
the Y men and sealed away within the
sacred realm along with the full
Triforce which implies that he also
retrieved the Triforce of wisdom from
Zelda following Link's death well
actually that bit right there is a
little bit of a head cannon from me what
a link to the past actually says
happened is Ganondorf just straight up
murdered all his minions so that he
alone could enter the sacred realm and
grab the Triforce for himself
successfully Wishing Upon it to rule the
world and corrupting the sacred realm
into the dark world it's a bit
contradictory though in several places
since it says that Ganondorf actually
was able to wish upon the Triforce which
means that for some reason the Triforce
wish worked instead of splitting apart
like it did when he tried to wish upon
it in Ocarina of Time and also it
implies the door to the sacred realm was
open and that Ganondorf then transformed
into Ganon inside the realm and was
sealed within it if this were true then
link would have still woken up seven
years later since he was asleep at this
time and likely would have you know done
something about the situation since it
literally is contradictory and actually
seems to reference events not linked to
Ocarina of Time I choose to personally
explain the Fallen timeline as link
being eliminated at the final battle of
Ocarina of Time and then the events that
A Link to the Past happens afterwards
but you can believe whatever you wish As
It ultimately doesn't matter much for
explaining the existence of Ganon the
point is his Triforce powered
transformation was into a two-legged
humanoid pig monster when he's defeated
for the first time at the end of a link
to the past the Triforce is not present
within him so he actually does die
completely he's halfway resurrected
again in the events of the Oracle games
via his surrogate mother's twin rova
although the resurrection is interrupted
by link and only a Mindless Ganon is
revived and subsequently killed later on
in A Link Between Worlds Yuga
specifically harnesses the power of the
seven maidens who are the descendants of
the wise men aka the sages to resurrect
and transform into Ganon or in this case
Yuga Ganon and of course is killed once
again by the hero of Hyrule and once
again later on in the timeline prior to
the events of the original Legend of
Zelda game Ganon is once again revived
by his lingering followers and leads an
assault against Hyrule in order to
obtain the Triforce of wisdom which
Zelda has broken and Scattered across
the land preemptively Ganon is once
again killed by link and technically
revived again in the next game Zelda 2
The Adventure of link if link dies
that's a big if though but I mean hey
maybe it spawns another Fallen timeline
off of the Fallen timeline so the fall
and Fallen timeline yeah that makes
sense with ganon's many different
appearances throughout the timelines
explained it's time to talk about his
latest appearances as Calamity Ganon and
dark Beast Ganon in breath of the wild
right off the bat and trust me I'm not
copying out of explaining it I'm just
avoiding full-on speculation by
admitting that it's hard to explain the
specifics of ganon's appearance here due
to breath of the wild not officially
connecting to any one of the previous
timelines and of course theories can be
made but this is not a timeline Theory
video so I digress the one thing that
carries over across all the timelines
though is the hatred of demise and what
I can say is that by the time of breath
of the wild Ganon is more of an idea
than an actual being that resurfaces
eternally sometimes spanning 10 000
years in between appearances and that
both Calamity Ganon and dark Beast Ganon
and heck even the blight ganons are all
made of the same goopy evil substance
referred to as malice none of which are
actual transformations of Ganondorf like
the other ganons from the timelines but
rather are puppets if you will or
perhaps Phantoms that are all
manifesting outside ganondorf's corpse
he's been able to make Phantom ganon's
before but it always used to be either
due to Gerudo dark magic or the power of
the Triforce of power so the real
question we should be asking is what is
malice specifically and where does it
come from I know people will immediately
say that malice as a substance has ties
way back to Skyward Sword in that it's
heavily implied that that's what
monsters are made out of in that game
but ganondorf's not a monster right he's
human or he was at some point so where
did the malice come from well with tears
of the Kingdom right around the corner I
think this very question is about to get
an answer and therefore Calamity Ganon
will finally be fully explained we
already know that it looks like malice
is coming from ganondorf's Corpse but
again he didn't used to ooze reddish
purple jelly out of his chest so
something must have changed maybe an old
foe was returning from their Eternal
Slumber and needs a physical body to
possess but before we dive headfirst
into speculation station I'm gonna go
ahead and pump the brakes there thank
you so much for watching and if you
enjoyed
bye
[Music]